let's go next to taylor from atlanta
georgia taylor welcome to the program
hey david how's it going it's going well
hey good talk to you
likewise uh i wanted to
just kind of bring up a thought or
opinion and get your thoughts on it okay
uh i guess
suggest the the culpability of the nra
is maybe a little bit more i mean sorry
a little bit less than what we're giving
it okay and i don't mean they i don't
mean their inaction you know isn't uh
maddening but
um
i think these issues with the guns and
like i don't think the gun lobby has
enough
as much power as we're saying they do
okay what and so why do you on what
particular issue so give like
be a little more specific
so just lobbying the you know the
senators and congress
to
so we're losing we're losing your audio
it's starting to get all all chopped up
i mean listen one of the things that i
think is important to consider is
most democrats and republicans want
total universal background checks
eliminating all loopholes to get around
it the nra is against that and the nra
directly funds
many of the elected officials
who are also against it so i think it
would be natural to be wondering
what is the effect of those donations it
seems natural to ask that question and
it seems the effect is probably some
yeah i agree but i'm saying there's
potentially other
factors at play i think there's a large
uh
concerted group of religious
fundamentalists yes that have in a way
buried themselves into politics
and so when i see people like ted cruz
on stage um
i essentially
don't see him saying like hey i'm on the
nra side he's saying don't vote me out
like don't replace me because
these people have come up with ways that
they're politically successful in that
they've done the math you need you have
a given percentage of people that vote
republican given percent that vote
democrat and so all they need to do is
address
the remaining three percent
right
that i don't disagree with that and and
oftentimes uh
the appeal to that slice it might be
bigger than three percent but the appeal
to that slice is based on a number of
wedge issues that are not even that
important to the bulk of the voters that
regularly vote one way or the other
that's that's the disturbing part
exactly exactly yeah
all right well thank you for the call i
appreciate your insights
thanks all right